you had a podcast not long ago where you
were talking about how Dawkins just
basically said that well religion does
have some benefits to society yeah and I
think he's realizing too that in Britain
in particular
uh a tepid secularism is not going to
resist a radical Islam but Christianity
could be just from a pragmatic point
point of view from his point of view can
maybe blunt radical Islam so he's
realizing there's some pragmatic uses to
religion but I think originally the new
atheism came out of 9 11 these
fundamentalists you know you know the
old saying that science will teach you
how to fly a plane but religion will
teach you how to fly a plane into a
building you know that kind of thing and
so they were really adamant against any
religion and they would plot or they
would put them all together Islam
Christianity all these religions are
just basically looked at with this
disdain at the time and I think people
starting to realize that's not really
the way the world works that's not
really true these religions are
different and they're they're different
for good reasons
all right we are at the local Studio
here in Miami Florida and joining me
today is the author of I don't have
enough Faith to be an atheist great
title man Frank Turk pleasure Dave it is
a pleasure great being here with you
thanks for coming to town you've come
from Charlotte North Carolina I
appreciate you making the Trek uh let's
start with the title yeah of this book I
don't have enough Faith to be an atheist
I didn't think of it my co-author so I
should say you are technically the
co-author of this book tell me a little
bit about your well Dr Norman Geisler
when he died he died in 2019. Dave they
added up the number of books either
wrote co-wrote or updated it was 129.
wow the man had written more books not
only than most people have read than
most people have seen because who goes
to the library anymore right right this
guy was brilliant and at one point he
and I were traveling the country doing a
a talk we called the 12 points that show
Christianity is true and he he went
through the fine-tuning argument that
the universe is fine-tuned so
incomprehensibly and after he got done
with this amazing presentation he
finally said in light of this I just
don't have enough Faith to be anything
and I went that needs to be the title of
the book so it really was a throwaway
line yeah he just I don't have enough
Faith to be an atheist so he said well
let's write the book so we wrote the
book based on the seminar we were doing
we sent it to the publisher and they
said we don't like the top title I said
you don't like the title what do you
think the title should be and they said
the truth about truth I said sorry
that's a deal breaker we're going to
another publisher they said okay we'll
stick with the title and thankfully they
did and the book came out in 2004. tell
me a little bit about how you two linked
up your Journeys to to get to the book
and then we'll dive into obviously yeah
the specifics of why you don't have
enough Faith to be I was in the Navy
which stands for never again volunteer
yourself for eight years
and but I came to Faith by reading books
by a man by the name of Josh McDowell I
was brought up in New Jersey so I was
Catholic because as you know in Jersey
it's the law you're either Catholic or
Jewish right yeah I went to Catholic
High School but I never knew who Jesus
was and uh when I was in the Navy I met
the son of a Methodist Minister and I
had so many questions for me he said
Frank you just need to get Josh McDowell
books evidence demands a verdict more
than a carpenter so I read those books
and I I began to realize that
Christianity is indeed true when I got
out of the Navy I happened to meet
Norman Geisler and he said I'm starting
a seminary in Charlotte why don't you
come down and check it out so we did and
six months later we moved the whole
family did you consider yourself a
Believer before that are you sort of
nominally Catholic or just secular
Northeast I became a believer in the
Navy by reading these books and then
starting to go to church and then when I
met Geisler who I didn't know at the
time but
to use a dated reference he was the
Michael Jordan of apologetics what we
call evidence for the faith at the time
and when I met him and looked him up I
said if I want to get into this field
this is the guy right you know it's like
in philosophy your friend Jordan
Peterson if he was still at the
University of Toronto and he was still
teaching and you wanted to learn that's
the guy right that he was he was the
Jordan Peterson of Christian apologetics
so the reason that I wanted to have you
on now and my producer Phoenix has been
mentioning you for quite some time is
that there seems to be something
interesting happening with the atheist
movement if we can call it a movement I
mean in essence it has basically Fallen
apart uh you know from Sam Harris sort
of Disappearing off Twitter and having
you know a lot of political problems
that whole four horsemen things sort of
disappeared the new atheist movement I
don't know if you've seen that the the
president of the I think atheists of
America David Silverman has basically
come out and said that the atheist
movement was a failure this is just in
the last two or three weeks or so I've
seen other a well-known atheists like
skeptic my friend Michael Shermer talk
about how there is a purpose and a need
for religion people fill that up with
something else and of course Jordan
Peterson talking about how people end up
believing whether they believe it or not
uh so there's something interesting
culturally happening right now which is
sort of why I wanted to bring you on I
wonder if you have any thoughts on that
just sort of what's happening right now
I think that the new atheist movement
Dave was a reaction to 9 11. uh because
at the time the new atheists at the time
were Christopher Hitchens I had a couple
of opportunities to debate him in the
2000s late 2000s uh also Richard Dawkins
and Sam Harris I don't know if you've
seen it in the last couple you had a
podcast not long ago where you were
talking about how Dawkins just basically
said that uh well religion does have
some benefits to society yeah and I
think he's realizing too that in Britain
in particular
a tepid secularism is not going to
resist a radical Islam but Christianity
could be just from a pragmatic point
point of view from his point of view can
maybe blunt radical Islam so he's
realizing there's some pragmatic uses to
religion but I think originally the new
atheism came out of 9 11. these
fundamentalists you know you know the
old saying that science will teach you
how to fly a plane but religion will
teach you how to fly plane into a
building you know that kind of thing and
so they were really adamant against any
religion and they would plot or they
would put them all together Islam
Christianity all these religions are
just basically looked at with this
disdain at the time and I think people
starting to realize that's not really
the way the world works that's not
really true these religions are
different and they're they're different
for good reasons yeah so
it's interesting because what you're
describing as the push the the Christian
sort of argument as the pushback against
radical Islam I think what we have here
is the pushback against woke is that
people and this is what David Silverman
from the the American atheist was saying
he did not realize that wokism was going
to become I think he called it a cult
not a religion and I think that's sort
of what what brings us to this moment in
America yes and Silverman uh was the
president-american atheist in fact I had
a debate with him probably seven or
eight years ago but then he left that
role I don't even know what he's doing
now I mean the whole movement maybe has
pretty much evaporated really yeah uh
Hitchens of course passed away uh
Dawkins is starting to realize there's
utility to religion from a pragmatic
point of view and I know it's going to
sound odd uh Dave but I have a lot of
respect for Richard Dawkins because he
has more courage than many American
pastors I mean Richard Dawkins has spoke
against wokism Richard Dawkins has said
I'm sorry there's only two genders it's
science right and Richard Dawkins has
talked about the problems with radical
Islam most pastors are hiding under
their desks on these issues they're not
coming out and talking about this so to
his credit Richard Dawkins has said some
things that I wish American pastors
would say so so what's going on there
let's dive into that a little bit
because it's not just pastors I mean
this is happening throughout throughout
Jewish synagogues it's happening through
almost every denomination of
Christianity where the rabbis the
pastors they're they're choosing wokism
they're choosing Equity over
religious teachings right right well
thinking it was going to bring more
people in I think what seems to be doing
the reverse yeah I don't know if I think
I think Christians have bought into the
idea that politics is sort of off the
table for them what they don't seem to
realize is that uh first of all their
ability to actually be Christians and
live the Christian faith and preach the
gospel so to speak is determined to a
certain extent by what laws are made
right I mean here we take it for granted
we have religious freedom but as you've
pointed out and many others it's
evaporating right uh so for no other
reason Christians ought to be involved
in politics is to protect the very
ability to preach and live the gospel
the second reason is I always ask
Christians this or anybody this should
Christians care how people are treated
everyone says well of course well should
by their government
well yeah that follows oh now now
suddenly you better care about politics
you better care about the rules that are
made because if you care about people
you've got to care about what's going on
and I think thankfully you and others
have been a champion for saying this
transgenderism issue particularly on
children should be off limits and
pastors even are afraid to talk about it
Dave yeah it's crazy
I know it's crazy and I see it every day
and and that's why one of the things
that's been interesting for me as
someone who's not Christian uh and
certainly Christian a certain set of
Christians might have some issues with
my lifestyle and everything else I have
found generally especially Evangelical
Christians to be the most welcoming
decent people out there which did help
me I think evolve in some ways in my
thinking yeah you had a uh I just
re-listened to it it was four years ago
that dialogue you had with my friend
John Lennox and Justin brierley yeah
yeah Lennox that was a great event if
every if every Christian was like John
Lennox the whole world would be
christianized because you can't not like
that unless he's right one guys smiling
right he's telling you this and joking
he's like he's like your favorite uncle
who has all these great stories and and
John is uh just one of the guys I look
up to in my field of work because he is
just so affable yet but yet so
intelligent he's a PhD in mathematics
and philosophy he's amazing so okay so I
would just want to return to the title
for a moment I don't have enough Faith
to be about this I think from an
American sort of broad cultural
perspective most people it's not that
they're atheists but they just sort of
don't know what they believe we have
just sort of a set of things that we
kind of wake up to every day a culture
War a political fire and then that's
kind of what they believe in the thing
that's happening sort of every day at
the moment and I think that sort of
leads people to a degree of craziness so
how would you unfurl if you think that's
a fair premise how would you kind of
unfurl people out of that well
I would there's two questions that need
to be answered uh does God exist and if
so what has he said those are the two
big questions all right let's do it
right let's go so does God exist
I think when somebody asks me how do I
know God exists I say I know God by his
effects
if there's a creation and there is this
universe at a beginning is even atheists
are admitting then there has to be a
Creator the creation is the effect that
causes the Creator right so they might
say it's the big bang and it was just a
bunch of gases and this well they
wouldn't say Miracle but they would say
just this thing happened this causeless
thing happened they will say that but it
seems to me that if space time and
matter had a beginning
the only thing that could have caused
that is something that transcends
space-time and matter in other words the
cause must be spaceless timeless
immaterial powerful to create the
universe out of nothing personal in
order to choose to create because
impersonal forces don't make choices
only a person can make a choice to go
from nothingness to a state of creation
the cause would also have to be
intelligent to have a mind to make a
choice so I always ask people I say when
you think about a spaceless Timeless
immaterial powerful personal intelligent
cause who do you think of and most
people say God but then they'll say well
how do you know it's the Christian God
and the answer is we don't know if it's
the Christian God unless because this
God could be Allah or some other
theistic God right unless Jesus rose
from the dead and if you can discover
that Jesus really did rise from the dead
then we can say that the same being that
walked out of the Tomb 1990 years ago is
the same being who's in whose divine
nature created the universe out of
nothing so you've gotta you don't get
all the way to Jesus from one argument
uh but if you can show that the Universe
had a beginning
and had a beginner with those attributes
and you can see that Jesus rose from the
dead then you could show that
Christianity is true that's just one of
several Arguments for God yeah feel free
to make a couple others why don't we go
through a couple yeah the second is the
teleological or the design argument
which is so incredibly difficult to
explain from an atheistic perspective
that even Christopher Hitchens said I
don't know how to explain this one right
uh for example the gravitational force
if it were altered more by more than one
in 10 to the 40th power that's one part
in one with 40 zeros following it we
wouldn't exist and an illustration I
like to give is this if you were to take
the entire North American continent from
Central America all the way to Greenland
stack it in dimes to the Moon 238 000
miles then do that on a billion other
North American continents take all those
dimes put them in one pile mark one dime
red mix it in blindfold a friend throw
them on the pile say pick one dime the
chances he would pick that one red dime
is one chance in 10 to the 40th power
he's not going to pick that dime right
so the implication here is and this is
just one of several factors about the
universe change any one of them we're
not here is that what best explains that
chance whatever that means or design I
mean either this value was designed or
it wasn't and it seems if we're going to
be rational we have to say it's designed
and as I say it's just one of several so
that's one aspect of the design argument
then when you get to biology and you see
that in every one of your 100 trillion
cells there's a software program 3.5
billion letters long
I mean if we were to go out to the beach
Right Here Right Now Dave and we're
walking along Miami Beach and it says
John loves Mary in the sand we wouldn't
go well the waves did that or you know
or crabs came out of the water and made
that message no we'd say that that
message had to come from a mind
well what happens when we find a message
that's 3.5 billion letters long in every
one of our 100 trillion cells if John
loves Mary requires a mind doesn't a
message 3.5 billion letters long require
mind seems to me that's an effect that
needs a cause like God
and then of course the third argument
that we often talk about which is
probably most germane to the topics you
talk about is the moral argument
because if there's no God everything's
just a matter of opinion there's no
standard Beyond us no Transcendent uh
standard of righteousness that were
obligated to obey then there's no
difference between Mother Teresa and
Hitler from a moral perspective right
it's just your opinion against somebody
else's opinion and so that argument I
think probably carries the most weight
with people today right so is that is
that the one you think that maybe led us
to so much of the craziness today when
we're debating as my friend Douglas
Murray often says things that we've put
to bed years ago and suddenly we're
debating you know whether boys or girls
or girls or boys it's because we have
sort of no moral basis anymore at scale
in society yeah it's it's a free-for-all
but the very people that are arguing for
that are arguing as if there's a moral
right to do this you notice because
everybody's trying to oppose a moral
position the only question is whose
moral position now all laws legislate
morality the only question is who's
morality and what I try and say to
people is I don't want to let legislate
my morality I don't want to legislate
your morality I want to legislate the
morality the one Thomas Jefferson said
was self-evident so that self-evident
morality upon which this nation was
found is the morality we ought to get
back to
um even though they were inconsistent
with it obviously on slavery and other
issues they were inconsistent but they
knew in their hearts in fact Jefferson
and the founding fathers knew that
slavery was going to be an issue that it
wasn't morally right they just couldn't
figure out how how to get rid of it at
the time I tell people all the time he
was writing the documents to free the
slaves as he himself was a slave owner
that's right he was just a man of his
time as as incredible as he was what
would you say to the line one of the
things that I think shifted me on a lot
of this uh Jordan Peterson uh you know
when we toured together it would come up
literally every single night people
would say please define God explain God
how did you become a Believer and and
the short answer he really didn't like
that question not because he didn't
think it was valuable but because it was
just coming up all the time right and he
felt that there's so many other things
to talk about and everything else but
the the simplest version of it would be
that he behaves as if God exists that's
what he would say and I thought that
that was that was pretty solid that that
was almost enough for most people do you
think that that's fair well the question
he can't sit there and tell you okay God
exists but he will behave in such a way
that right I think Jordan takes more of
a utilitarian approach to God that
whether he exists or not we better
believe in him because if we don't it's
going to be as Dostoevsky or as doskey
said you know if there is no God
everything's permissible right it's
going to be chaos as Nietzsche pointed
out uh however I think there's evidence
that God exists and I think you can show
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt not beyond all
doubt I could be wrong right but I think
that God does exist and if Jesus rose
from the dead and I think we can give
evidence that he did then the Christian
God is the true God
uh so if that's the case who is God
God in the abstract is spaceless
timeless immaterial powerful personal
and intelligent In the Flesh he's Jesus
he's he adds Humanity to his deity and
he comes to Earth not to give us some
sort of new moral code but to but to be
our substitute he is the one that lives
the perfect life in our place so by
trusting in Him we can have our moral
transgressions forgiven and we can be
given his righteousness so Christianity
contrary to what many will say is not a
system that tries to get you to live
better Christianity is a system that
tries to get you to accept the
substitute and because you do accept
this accept the substitute out of
gratitude for what he's done for you
then you will live a moral life
it's a result in other words so what
would the the role of
in your perfect world what would the
role of Christianity be in say the
United States
well I believe in freedom of religion
and I think God does too otherwise he'd
be pestering us all the time right he
gives us enough Freedom uh in order to
go our own way so I I think we have
freedom of religion and I would not want
any sort of Theocratic government but I
think what people confuse Dave on this
issue is
I I just remember I'll bring up a name
from the past remember old Chris
Matthews of course yeah Chris before
MSNBC went completely invested right oh
he was like kind of hanging on by a
thread that's right he used to say we
can't set up some sort of theocracy and
I would say Chris we're not talking
about telling people where when how or
if to worship we're not telling them
they have to be a certain religion that
would be establishing a religion but we
can't avoid telling people how they
ought to treat one another and that's
legislating morality and everybody's
trying to do that I mean it's what the
woksters are doing yeah yes that's what
they're doing the question the only
question is who's morality so I think
and I'll Pro part with some of my my
Christian friends here Christian this
country was not founded on Christianity
it was founded on the moral law
consistent with Christianity when when
Jefferson says we hold these truths to
be self-evident that we're endowed by
our creator
he what he wanted to do was have a new
government that wasn't completely
relativistic and have no God but he
didn't want a government like they came
from England and said you got to be a
member of the Church of England right he
wanted to have the best of both worlds
religious freedom but also moral
absolutes to come from God so he said
we're gonna we're gonna establish this
on the moral law that comes from God's
nature that moral law we know comes from
the same God that wrote the Bible or
inspired the Bible but you don't have to
be a Christian to know it you don't have
to be a Christian to be a citizen here
this this nation has opened everyone
that's the kind of government I think we
ought to have is that the Brilliance of
the line self-evident more than anything
else because that there again when I
quote this line about Douglas Murray
that were that were debating things that
shouldn't be debated anymore it seems to
me we're in this odd spot right now
we're we're culturally nothing
self-evident anymore there's nothing
that's just settled what what is settled
anymore nothing was JFK fascinated did
we go to the Moon our boys girls Etc et
cetera oh yeah it is crazy in that
regard and I think part of that is the
is what happens to use a Biblical phrase
that when you suppress the truth long
enough
God gives you up to a depraved mind I
mean to the point where you you don't
even know there's a the difference
between boys and girls by the way
transgenderism presupposes men and women
because if if I'm a man and I think I'm
a woman I have to have some idea what a
man is and some idea what a woman is to
know I have this mismatch between my
psychology and my biology if I did if
there weren't fixed genders I wouldn't
be able to know that also if I'm going
to try and make the so-called transition
I have to have some idea what a man is
and some idea what a woman is in order
to make the transition so on one hand
they're trying to say oh gender is
completely fluid on the other hand it
would be impossible transgenderism be
impossible if there weren't fixed gender
you know it's interesting because one of
the things I've been talking about on
the show is when it's the same argument
I've made it slightly different way
which is that with kids they're taking a
young boy who maybe likes the color pink
or Barbie on one hand they're telling
you none of this matters and on the
other hand they're saying oh he likes
pink and Barbie thus he must be a girl
that's right so it's the most radically
authoritarian while it's also saying
it's the most tolerant and diverse and
everything else which I suppose that
doesn't surprise you because it's
disconnected it is it's it's when when
you when you
when you move away from God even just
say a generic God the god of of right
and wrong when you move away from that
God's a gentleman he he gives up on you
he eventually he says I know you don't
want me so I'm going to pull myself away
God is not going to force you into his
presence against your will and from a
theological perspective that's what hell
is hell is separation from God because
God will not force you into his presence
against your will I always say
if if you don't want God now you're not
going to want him in eternity why would
he why would he say you're with me now
in eternity no he's gonna pull himself
away and the problem is if if this is
true of Christianity is true and I think
it is
then the worst place you can be is
separated from God because he is this he
is the source of all love he is the
source of all goodness he is the
standard I mean you've been talking
about this you've been talking about
there's got to be some sort of
Transcendence out there there has to be
something Beyond this that's right it's
not just this it's just not it's just
yes I know I know that much and maybe
that's part of the reason going back to
your original question Dave that the new
atheism doesn't
or has faded away because people know
there's something Transcendent we're not
just molecular machines we're not just
moist robots yeah right and if we are
moist robots why should we believe
atheism is true we shouldn't believe our
thoughts because our thoughts are
completely driven by the laws of physics
according to them
so materialism is really self-defeating
and that's the the main atheistic view
now in fact Thomas Nagel who I think
John Lennox mentioned in your dialogue
with him he's an NYU Professor wrote a
book about 12 years ago called mind and
Cosmos where he said even though he's an
atheist he said
I'm trying to remember the subtitle he
said something like why the Neo
darwinian materialistic Viewpoint of the
world is almost certainly false
and he got so much pushback from his
fellow atheists because he's essentially
saying look I know there's something
Transcendent out there I'm an atheist I
don't know how to explain it but
materialism isn't the answer materialism
makes us moist robots why should anyone
listen to me why should I listen to
myself it's just not that fun it's not
that sellable I think that that's part
of it also there's no imagination there
I got in I don't know if you saw it but
I got into a bit of a debate about
belief taking the believer's side with
Bill Maher on his podcast not too long
ago and it just struck me as oh you
don't believe in any anything sort of
magical it's like that's such a
fundamental part of Being Human whether
we could Whittle this down into the firm
belief in Christianity or any other
religion that the the need to believe is
just innate yes and and you will believe
in something one way or another yeah and
you've mentioned this and Jordan
Peterson has mentioned this everybody
has some kind of God there's a hierarchy
of values and there's something at the
top of all of our priority lists so what
would you say so you mentioned you've
debated Christopher Hitchens on this
when you when you look at someone like
hitch or you look at say Carl Sagan or
even Albert Einstein the people that
were sort of I don't know that Allentown
was fully not he thought that God didn't
play dice with the universe was the
famous line but when you look at the
people that were sort of not religious
per se
somewhat separated from belief but
clearly lived good inquisitive
interesting lives you know didn't do
harm as far as I can tell something like
that what would you say about that sort
of character that that person well I
certainly have always said and I said
this to Hitchin several times when I
said
Christopher I'm not saying that since
you're an atheist you can't do good
things I'm not saying you don't know
what right and wrong is everybody does
what I'm saying is you can't justify
what right and wrong is you can't
um
you you can know it and you can do it
but you can't justify why it's good if
there's no God it's just your opinion I
sometimes give an analogy I notice
there's a lot of speed limit signs
around here in Miami have you seen these
people yeah we have a lot of different
cultures here it's a real thing and
there's cameras everywhere anyway you
can go outside and see speed limit 35
miles an hour and you can obey that
speed limit sign while you deny there's
a traffic Authority but there would be
no speed limit sign unless there was a
traffic Authority the same thing is true
with God you can know that say murder's
wrong and deny there's a God
and you cannot murder do good things and
deny there's a God but it wouldn't be
wrong to murder from an objective point
of view unless there was a god
so and what would hitch's answer have
been on that or what was it well hitch
was so rhetorically gifted he would
never directly answer a question and and
here's uh I I don't try and judge my own
debates but I will say this the first
debate I Ever Had other with other than
with my wife which I lose repeatedly but
the first debate I ever had was against
Christopher Hitchens and um
it during the debate literally Dave I
was sitting there going I like this guy
I didn't even know what he was talking
about because he was all over the map
but you know just his his accent and his
wit great just he was just fabulous you
know and I'm kind of daydreaming going I
really like this guy
and I think people in the audience when
they're watching the debate they're
doing the same thing but if you look at
the transcript of the debate
and you're reading it you're going
what's he talking about this has nothing
to do with even the topic you know the
first debate was called does God exist
so I got up and I tried to give some of
the arguments we already mentioned you
know what he got up and started doing he
started talking about how Mother Teresa
was a bad person
and I was just baffled and going what
does this have to do with whether or not
God exists Mother Teresa may have been
good or bad that's not the point what
about God and He just never engaged
unfortunately he's not here so we can't
we can't really rehash it but would you
say that the flaw
if if he and some of these other people
I mentioned lived roughly decent lives
and everything else would you say that
the flaw is more functional in that it
just can't scale
what do you mean by that so that it
can't so it can work for sort of very in
individual people I have no doubt that
you believe that an individual atheist
could live a perfectly moral and good
life not perfectly okay so yeah yeah uh
within within the concept of being a
human being right could live a fairly
moral and decent life and everything
else but that it just sort of can't
scale over time it just doesn't give you
enough for generations to pass on to
live in some sort of functional way I I
know and I think that's sort of why this
American atheist thing collapsed and
sure movement is collapsed but I know
it's going to sound odd but I don't
think the purpose of life is to live a
moral life I think the purpose of life
is to know God and make him known
and if you do do that you will live a
moral life in other words it's a result
it is not the cause because we're all
fallen and if God is God which means
he's infinitely just
I've been unjust in my life even today
just coming over here how many people
did I cut off because I was late right
okay I'm I'm unjust every day and if God
is infinitely just at the Judgment I'm
in trouble and so I need somebody to
cover my sin somebody to pay for my sin
an unpopular word in today's culture but
it's it's
transgression against God or other
people
I've done that I do it all the time so I
need somebody to cover my sin that's why
Jesus came the son of man did not come
to be served but to serve and to give
his life as a ransom for many
and that's this is the only religion in
the world Dave that actually
is built on Grace rather than Works in
other words you don't earn
favor with God he just gives it to you
and then because he's given it to you
then you live a life out of gratitude to
him that will live in a moral way you
will live in a moral way that's the so
connected to that how much of what you
think is happening sort of culturally in
America right now and really all over
the world as you may know I just spent
about 12 days in Israel yes and when you
know to all of the holy sites and went
to the church of Holy cycle and went to
the to them you did some college work
there didn't you in the Negev uh yeah
that was 20 something years it was a
long time ago
um but one of the things that that
struck me was that the story it was very
clear especially being in Jerusalem for
about five days that you know they're
digging down and Excavating and
uncovering history and then they're also
building up I mean the city is just
absolutely flourishing it was amazing
what I kept thinking was people don't
know history and because they don't know
history they can't even connect any of
the the philosophic underpinning so we
just sort of all walk around spinning
all day long and and we need to know
history to know some of this stuff oh
absolutely and from uh we go to Israel
every every year we we bring a group to
Israel in fact Ellie shukron who is the
archaeologist who discovered the pool
Asylum and EXO excavated well we went
down there it's being excavated yeah I
know yeah well he excavated it back in
2004 and that church there Believe It or
Not didn't want him to continue the
excavation and somehow they just got
approval last year to finish it and so
Ellie who is the guy originally
discovered it is normally our tour guide
when we go we're going to go in November
again and he discovered that he also
discovered what might be and this is and
this is an amazing Discovery if it's
true I've seen it myself he thinks he's
he has found a standing Stone in this
city of David which goes all the way
back potentially to Melchizedek now this
is Abraham's time so this is 2000 BC
uh and that's right there in the city of
David this is a thousand years before
David
uh so he's he's an amazing archaeologist
and there's no question this was the
Jewish homeland long before anybody else
ever got there uh other than the
Canaanites who were there you know prior
to them right so this whole political
argument I think is just overcome by
archeology when you're down there and
you and so we did the walk through the
city of David and they're Excavating it
now you can go basically from the pool
all the way right to what would be what
would have been the temple Ellie
excavated that too yeah right so yeah
um when you're there and you're with the
archaeologist are most of the
archaeologists Believers or are they
more purely people Ellie is certainly a
believer in Yahweh he's a Jew Orthodox
Jewish believer
um
I don't know I can't speak for the
others I just know Ellie personally
um
but there are Americans as you know that
go over there quite a bit that do
excavate guys like Scott Stripling who
just discovered one of the oldest uh
inscriptions ever found in Israel up in
shechem which is uh Mount ebal next to
mount garazim and that that's he thinks
he's found that near Joshua's altar so
this would be say 1400 BC or 1200 BC
somewhere in there
uh he's a Christian and he excavates
quite a bit over there there are several
other guys but uh as you know Israel is
every time uh you you stick a spade in
the ground there's there's another
Discovery different layers that's right
something there's a layer cake they
described it to us on our walk of city
of David as as a Tiramisu basically
you're just going through and there's
just another layer and another layer of
Ash and they can just it's incredible so
would you say so as a Christian would
you say that that Christianity then
in essence is sort of part two or just
the continuation of the story that that
the Jewish Bible came out of that that
sort of didn't end
purely with the ending of of the Old
Testament right the Old Testament
pre-figures Jesus and predicts Jesus one
of the most astounding prophecies in the
Old Testament of course is Isaiah 53 the
suffering servant passage written 700
years before Christ came it talks about
this servant taking our iniquities on
himself that he is the Lamb that goes to
the slaughter and so when you see that
written 700 years before Jesus yeah you
go wow there's something to this and
there's other people do you think that
was like a nugget or uh what would they
in a video game it's like what do they
call in the video game like the secret
thing in a video game they give an
Easter egg
there it is you know and then they know
that that that it's there so how do you
combine those two things obviously Jews
still exist sure Israel still exists of
course yeah and there's a future for for
Israel as well and it's amazing when you
think about it as as you know Dave
there's no country in the history of the
world that left its Homeland for nearly
2 000 years came back to to it speaking
the same language how does that happen
and in Isaiah I think it's Isaiah 11 he
says he's going to bring the nation into
the land a second time 1948 it happened
so
yeah and you've pointed out others have
pointed out
think about how much land
um Arabs have in the Middle East
we've got New Jersey for the Jews and 20
of them are Arab citizens that have full
voting rights yeah so I I'm having a
hard time figuring out
why uh certain people there don't want
the Jews to have a Homeland in fact my
friend Michael Brown has put it this way
maybe somebody maybe maybe attributed Dr
Brown he says this
if the Palestinians or if if the Israel
Israelites laid down their weapons there
would be no more Israel if the
Palestinians laid down their weapons
there'd be no more war yeah I think
ultimaire may have said that yeah maybe
several years ago so we only have about
five minutes okay so this went by very
quickly yes how can we wrap this all up
in in a way that gives the average
person who's watching my show I think my
show one of the things that I'm very
proud of is I think we have a nice
cross-section of sort of atheists and
Believers and people of all different
walks of life what would be the main
thing that you think would would sort of
unite them in all of this whether
they're fully a Believer or fully a
Christian or they come more from the
secular world or whatever well I guess
the one question I would ask people and
I do this on college campuses because I
speak on a lot of college campuses and
then we have open mic the question I
always ask you don't get people don't
get shouted off the college campuses uh
with all this radical stuff you're
speaking well because I'm going giving
the evidence that Christianity is true
um not necessarily given a political
message
uh although I talk about politics all
the time but it's not the focus of what
I'm doing you know my friend Charlie
Kirk and I'm sure you and others you'll
get shouted down and Shadow down with
Charlie yeah yeah and uh so you guys
will take more heat because of the angle
you're coming from sure it's probably
going to happen soon to me but anyway on
a college campus if someone gets up to
the microphone and expresses any
hostility at all or normally stop and
ask this one question I'll say if
Christianity were true would you become
a Christian
and I Dave I've had atheists stand at
that microphone in front of hundreds of
people and say no
see no wait wait wait I thought you
claimed to be reasonable and rational
how is it reasonable you wouldn't
believe something if it were true well
it's not about reason it's not about the
mind it's about the heart they don't
want it to be true they don't want there
to be a God why because they want to be
God of their own lives they're not on a
truth Quest they're on a happiness Quest
and they're just going to do whatever
they think is going to make them happy
and here's the problem you can make
yourself happy over the short term doing
a lot of fun but selfish things however
over the long term it's a disaster and
most of us that have passed 40 begin to
realize this we go I just can't live for
myself all the time if I do that I'm
never going to have a good relationship
I'm never going to find what really is
right about life there's going to be
trouble and what I say to people is look
if you want true contentment you got to
go straight through truth and Jesus is
the truth check it out the problem is
most people are looking for God like a
criminal is looking for a cop right they
want to go their own way and so God is a
gentleman he lets people go their own
way but he I think he gives us let me
sum it up this way he gives us enough
evidence to know that he exists and he
gives us enough evidence to know how he
wants us to live but not so much that we
can't be free and go our own way if we
don't want to
and that's what a gentleman does right
that kind of sounds like the message of
America if I'm not mistaken yeah well
the founders knew Dave I mean
this this
three branch system where the
legislature is supposed to be the
superior branch
they don't they don't they don't
exercise that very well yeah but the
founders knew that human beings are
inherently selfish
as as uh
as Madison said if men were Angels no
government would be necessary right they
knew that we needed checks and balances
because of the Fallen human heart yet
the left now they think people are
inherently good that's the fundamental
in my view the fundamental problem with
leftism they think people are inherently
good and they're gonna they don't need
incentives to to stay in line they're
just going to do the right thing no
they're not we're imperfect people we
can't create a perfect system that's
right that's right Frank I wish we had
more time I really do brother thank you
God bless you thank you for having me
all right on thank you if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality check
out our spirituality playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell